automakers have received billions of
dollars in subsidies and tax incentives
to build factories in the US and create
American jobs a new CBS News primetime
series CBS n on assignment uncovers the
hidden foreign workers who are building
sections of US auto plants our
investigation took us thousands of miles
from South Carolina to Slovenia in
Central Europe in search of answers it
was hard for me to believe because I
just didn't understand why they would be
here for three years
Gerald Greiner managed safety on
American construction projects for a
German contractor called Eisenman his
first job was at Mercedes in Vance
Alabama in 2013 there was polish and
Slovenian and Croatian people there what
do they do
anywhere from steel erection to pipe
fitting to pouring concrete to
installing equipment just about
everything the cars will be built by
American workers it's just the building
of these plants that it's being done by
farming exactly yeah they come into
groundbreaking they're done at started
production did you think to yourself
that the job is that these guys were
doing could be done by Americans oh yeah
absolutely yes our investigation led us
to this apartment complex in Spartanburg
South Carolina where it appeared workers
from Slovenia and Croatia were being
housed by their employer
we found them around 6:30 a.m. the
workers had one last cigarette and
headed to work a band that we're looking
at right now is the van that is carrying
the workers that we've just been staking
out and the plants not too far from
where we're going so I'm gonna shoot a
little bit of it driving away another
CBS producer filmed the van of workers
going through BMW security at 6:45 a.m.
the lower the camera we showed up at the
plant a few minutes later we know that
our producer who's been here since you
know 5:30 in the morning five o'clock in
the morning has shot at at least 15 and
now probably more vans and vehicles
filled with these workers from Eastern
Europe angry
Daniel drove antsy has worked for the
local 104 sheet metal workers union out
of San Jose California for more than a
decade there's lots of guys out there
still looking for work here and now we
have how many thousands and thousands of
East Indian workers working here and
they're abused to let this happen
automakers declined our request for an
interview in statements they said their
contractors are legally obligated to
comply with all immigration safety and
employment laws and any violations are
promptly addressed so how these you
Eastern European workers getting into
the United States and what kind of visas
do they get they're essentially coming
in on tourist visas charlie and in doing
so they're exploiting a loophole that
allows them to work in the United States
but not to work the jobs that we
uncovered them working Thank You Vlad
you can watch our full report made in
America tonight on CBS n on assignment
that's at 10:00 9:00 central here on CBS